bon alors tout de suite on reçoit madame
lalande sylvie la langue qui est la
présidente démissionnaire du de capital
régional et coopératif desjardins qui
est tout juste d'arriver en studio
bonsoir dame lalande soir monsieur
fillon merci de votre patience
c'est sûr présentes pourquoi vous
démissionner parce que c'est très
difficile de poursuivre en diffamation
ministre qui active les leviers
financiers de l'institution pour
laquelle vous présidez le conseil
d'administration alors mordre la main
qui le nourrit c'est pas une situation
confortable pour personne parce que
desjardins n'était pas à l'aise avec le
fait que vous ayez déposé une mise en
demeure à l'endroit de monsieur fait
tribun je pense que tout le monde aurait
souhaité d'avoir que de ministre
s'excuse rapidement ce qui devrait
donner la chance de passer à autre chose
mais comme je n'ai pas reçu d'excusés
formelles
j'ai dû prendre ma décision et faire un
choix et j'ai fait deux chouettes
regagner mon intégrité de mme attaquer
dès maintenant à rétablir ma réputation
et m'ont été mieux que c'est le choix
que j'ai fait était incompatible avec le
fait de demeurer comme prison mais si
vous avez raison qu'il n'y a pas de
conflit d'intérêts ou qu'il n'ya pas
d'apparence de conflit d'intérêts
pourquoi partir parce que monsieur
legault a fait des menaces à peine
voilées à l'effet qu'il pourrait
modifier les avantages que pourraient
dont pourraient bénéficier capitale
régionale déjà monsieur legault a dit
que les programmes
il faut toujours réexaminer les
programmes faisant écho donc au crédit
d'impôt là et qui sont disponibles pour
desjardins capital de risque et le fonds
de solidarité ftq les considérer que
c'est donc une menace à peine voilée à
peine voilée tout à fait et donc pour
cette raison là vous allez messieurs
louis je ne veux pas mettre davantage
d'autres parties prenantes au coeur de
cette tempête médiatique qui dans le
fond concerne plus directement monsieur
fils que john et moi au premier plan au
deuxième plan bien sûr il ya d'autres
victimes collatérales n'ai-je pas ici ce
soir prend pas comme présidente du
conseil de capitale régionale des
jardins est-ce que vous reconnaissez
qu'il peut y avoir apparence de conflit
d'intérêts puisque vous êtes associé à
quebecor au conseil d'administration
vous êtes président du groupe tva sur le
conseil d'administration
quebecor s'intéresse à capital médias
desjardins n'a pas voulu finalement
investir dans captain me dire jusqu'à
maintenant du moins est-ce que vous
reconnaissez qu'il y a apparence de
conflit d'intérêts
non et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
capitale régionale des jardins reçoit
entre 700 et 800 dossiers de demande de
financement parallèle aucun des
administrateurs n'est automatiquement en
apparence de conflit d'intérêts sur la
base qu'une demande a été présentée aux
équipes de direction il y à ce qu'on
appelle des seuil de matérialité le
seuil de matérialité du dossier de
groupes capital médias étaient telles
qu'il ne pensait même pas par un comité
investissement qui est un niveau
inférieur aux aussi que regarde le
conseil d'administration là c'est comme
je disais aux gens de caisse de dépôt
qui sont dans votre émission ce soir
c'est comme lorsque monsieur fils jaden
était au conseil de la caisse de dépôt
c'est comme si tous les dossiers qui
entrait en demande de financement à la
caisse de dépôt que lui et les autres
administrateurs du conseil se trouvait
automatiquement en apparence de conflit
d'intérêts parce qu'il ya eu évidemment
la demande ne s'est jamais rendu à la
grille de départ mais est ce que il n'ya
pas quand même le pouvoir d' influence
de votre part même si vous ne me tuent
dié pas le dossier vous êtes là vous
êtes les capitales régionales desjardins
qu'est-ce qui est pas aux apparences ça
fait 17 ans que je siège aux deux
conseils d'administration
jamais en aucun cas que je ne me serais
mise dans une situation qui de près ou
de loin
monsieur rémy en apparence de conflit
d'intérêts
donc vous allez poursuivre monsieur fait
ce que je vais poursuivre monsieur
fiscal il faut payer vos frais d'avocat
moi même personnellement
pourquoi vous remercier pierre karl
péladeau dans votre lettre parce que il
a été parce que d'abord il me connaît ce
n'est pas quelqu'un qui ne me connaît
pas c'est quelqu'un avec qui je
travaille depuis de nombreuses années et
ce quelqu'un qui a été témoin de mon
intégrité et je le remercie encore de
s'être portés à la défense d'une
personne qu'il connaît et je dirais et
il est capable de témoigner de mon été
monsieur fait tiquer bonne bien grillage
et j'espère je vous lis sa déclaration
de monsieur chinois chou oui je viens
d'apprendre que madame lalande a
démissionné du ca de capital régional et
coopératif desjardins je vais préciser
que ni le premier ministre ni moi
n'avons suggéré de retirer les crédits
d'impôt aux fonds fiscalisés
au contraire je suis présentement en
discussion avec luc ménard le mineur qui
est le président et chef de la direction
de desjardins capital qui est le
gestionnaire d actifs de déchanter
carter alors monsieur fidrych bendichou
en discussion avec luc ménard sur les
façons de développer la collaboration
entre capital régional et coopératif
desjardins le gouvernement
pour appuyer le développement de nos
régions je suis désolé que l'impact de
mes questions légitimes sur l'apparence
de conflit d'intérêts de madame lalande
et que lui portait offense ce n'était
pas mon intention
est-ce que vous n'auriez pas pu cesser
sur le cse oui moi je rêvais ce que 24
heures après que le ministre faisait 26
excuses et il a semé le doute dans
l'esprit de tous les citoyens à l'effet
que j'étais en conflit d'intérêts en
invitant les journalistes à aller
regarder qui était au conseil de crcd
insinuant par là que j'avais j'étais
intervenu où j'avais créé de
l'interférence en a tous moi c'est ça
que c'est ça que je reste je comprends
donc ça passait et ça passe toujours par
des excuses ça passe et ça va toujours
passer par des excuses de sorte que moi
je puisse à partir de maintenant
rétablir ma réputation
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
pierre karl péladeau comme quoi pierre
fitzgibbon a tenu des propos rétrogrades
à votre endroit
j'ai lu la lettre que monsieur péladeau
a envoyé à monsieur françois legault et
dans cette lettre là encore une fois
monsieur péladeau a pris le temps de
témoigner de son indic d'indignation
parce qu'on s'attaquait à mon intégrité
personnelle
c'est ce que sa lettre disait mais sur
twitter il a parlé de propos rétro et
voyez pas ça quand aussi oui oui oui
bien sûr je suis d'accord avec vous mais
deux d'accord avec lui à l'effet que à
l'effet que monsieur fait que ben a tenu
des propos rétrogrades
j'aurais préféré que ma chaussette bun
vérifie les faits avant d'insinuer que
j'avais créé de l'interférence ça c'est
mon souhait à moi merci beaucoup madame
lalancette un plaisir c'est de voir
rhétorique nous sommes ici